hey what's up guys my name is Samuel
leaves on sat with my friend David Wow
and he's on the property masters Academy
he's bought 11 houses over the last year
they haven't all completed yet some of
them have completed some of them are
about to complete some of them a whole
mixture but I just couldn't not bring
you on winners Wednesday when you've got
all these houses that you bought yeah I
mean you've learnt absolutely loads we
can draw out those lessons but firstly
thanks so much for coming down to the
office yeah I know some of you thanks
for inviting me is it good tell me your
life right now
ha ha ha yeah one obviously really
pleased you know I've got top action
like you said your articles and and
literally just just you know go ahead
with these 11 house 11 I was 11 yeah
yeah I mean I'm foreign with actually my
wife because I got her on board right
Lily watch the crash course yeah III
went to crash cause obviously when I
told my wife yeah buying these
properties who she was very skeptical
with the whole thing about almost
everyone was skeptical yeah you know the
debts you know that you know I owe and
and you know how am I gonna pay off all
the properties or the or the mortgages
and so forth I mean I tried to explain
to her but yeah but then you thought
you'd let me explain
yeah got a skeptical partner
but you someone actually at the last
class course I just went to there was a
woman there and she said that she's only
there because she watched a video that I
did and basically apparently I said if
your partner's unsupportive just leave
them oh my gosh so she was there to be
that supportive partner she ended up
being like absolutely you know in love
of the idea so your wife came then and
she's she didn't come yet you think
she's not even being she hasn't been
chef but you you've converted her I hope
I hope yes your first house yeah you
bought that one last year last year I've
got you
how's that one going that's being rented
out already okay and um and that's
before I met you
okay that's before you see where did you
buy that one I bought that in Liverpool
how much both for 30 grand
and how did you write it out for 450 so
you bought it for 30 grand
and your intern you have a 450 that's
right dude man you didn't need my crash
course it sounds like you care me well I
did do yeah they'd have to because the
things you told me about how I can
remortgage refinance interest only
because when I when I when I bought this
house was at first it was it was paint
capital and interest so I was paying
like 420 to pound a month okay and I
couldn't get my head around when I came
to your crash course a old pay interest
only and you know get the most album you
know from the Reds I'm so I a bit what
you asked and took action and went to
the bank and say look can I refinance
this you own the house up already you
know and which has to do refinance and
it was a chance for first house yes that
was that know what you know 30 grand it
they've evaluated 465 ground what yeah
so how much money do you spend on it
five grand deposit yeah possibly about
15 grand
refurb so you bought into 30 grand
you spent 15 or so 90-foot 45 in and
then you be financed there's 65 pounds
pulling all of your money out exactly
and then with that lower you then now
buy more houses I bought nice what you
love to buy what my second one okay
let's make a point I if you did that
before going on my crash course I mean
that's remarkable you bought a house for
30 grand
depending if they loved it then you've
got it we've over 65 pulled out all the
money I'm just I'm you know I'm
impressed
yeah the 65 place thanks to you really
because I would have to still continue
paying 422 pound mortgage without
meeting you because I wouldn't know that
you know you can actually mortgage free
interest only and get all the get to
income and you making yeah that's got to
income one is the rental
Theodore's capital appreciation well
yeah sure which obviously I got that out
from the refinance ready and going onto
the interest only I'm renting at for 450
the interest-only payments are actually
cent a pound
yeah Wow yeah - two four four hundred
and twenty-two thousand previously paid
let me ask you a question and Dave why
is it better because you told me that
you
go off to get your head around it so if
anyone was watching why is it better to
have interest-only do you think versus
repayment it's good debt isn't it so you
know even though I'm paying like a sick
all it explains my wife the 78 pounds
like a service fee for the bank yeah
really okay its interest but your
service fee I'm not gonna get anything
but how that's PR my I like that but but
what I'm getting in afterward you know
the service II I'm getting 350 pound
back now because I putting the money to
do the refurbishment and so on that's
350 in a year I gain what three three
thousand pound more than three different
pound back and you know that will pay
back in itself you know all the
refurbishment I paid before but then it
becomes my income as well well one house
income and but in addition to that I
explained to my wife me spending that
five grand 15 grand on the refresh when
I now have a second house because when I
refinance this house the money that I
was able to pull out I mean I cook with
the money got 20-round back into my fat
invited in I use that as well yeah for
the bonus like that I thought the idea
of saying yeah after service babe yeah
because the debt the mortgage which is
there is actually serving you it's your
friends yeah yeah so that's that make
sense rather than most people say I'm
gonna use all my money I want to pay off
my debt as fast as I can but then what
then you end up with a couple of houses
that you own outright that are giving
you five hundred pound each a month but
then why not use all of that money that
you put towards paying off a debt why
not use that towards put that down
deposits on more houses and then have
much better cash flow get much better
leverage as bit as they appreciate value
yeah just make sense that's right yeah
when you learned that you went crazy I
was I was I mean I mean when the moment
when I took action and took that
refinance I saw what happened but I got
47 grand out you know from from
obviously the bank double down to 65
they lend you what seven percent yeah so
I get for some I paid off the first land
at the 22 grand that I owe supposed to
be 25 if I did pay interest on it but
because I was paying capital in the
first year yeah so so therefore though I
was in 25
more than 22 so with that I was left
with about 20 26 grand 24 because with
the with the legal fees
I used that putting the depositor bought
a secondhand issued that's incredible
and it was a second house which I was
following your your videos actually you
ran told us to buy you know our free
bedroom look out for free bread from
house less than a hundred grand and you
know convert the front room it was a it
was free better upstairs yeah and the
room front delivery room bounced there
was you know convert that into another
bedroom so we have your four four
bedroom HMOs I bought the second house
for 85 grand I used those money that I
we found Anne's put a deposit down the
second house
oh my which means I didn't pay any you
know deposit second three hours it's
like the free house except the obvious
last thing you put money into for the
refurbishment okay which works on a
fourteen grand
yeah and I'm convert the house into a
full bedroom HMO and so other men would
just wait listen listen that like listen
before we I don't want people watching
they have to think Dave just went crazy
for 11 houses you know that you put a
lot of research before you buy a house
is a lot of things there's a lot of due
diligence a lot of research of these two
going at the house I'd love to talk to
you a bit about that but then also the
the due diligence the house but then
also if you're doing a refurb on it
you can't just grab I mean you try and
grab them doubles off the internet how
did that work out for you it didn't
really work the bit I want to get the
lessons from your mistakes not just in
your mistakes but also from your
learnings and from your your hardship so
let's start with the houses how how do
you go about finding a good area like
you've you've chosen Liverpool why did
you choose Liverpool I live in the pub
yes although I I was made in Hong Kong
and developing Eukarya but I I lived
most of my life in Liverpool so I know
quite well
yeah area the bad already good the area
so if you've been buying houses in the
in the bad parts of Liverpool or in the
good part or in the okay part I will
call it the okay part because the thing
is a it the area that I bought a lot of
people think of that bad my first house
was right by the air
football ground yeah and that area isn't
the greatest there's there's a lot of
antisocial behavior years obviously when
the football game comes in there's a lot
of people around those streets but
because III when they're on the street
in an evening time lunchtime and morning
time I just drive there to see if
there's a hit in the morning time go to
school
afternoon time any people who are still
in the house coming out which means
there's a lot of you know people not
maybe not working even in time to sit
there just see you know what's the
speaker's like whether it's quiet you
know there's a lot of noises and
anti-social behavior and I found this
first I was even last year I went before
I met you that bus but that's how I kind
of do my due diligence about what they
it's like good um so I bought that house
and bought these other houses because of
the area yeah now the Builder you you
were asking yes I want to come onto the
Builder okay right now I want to really
get an audit of area and find the houses
that you found as well yeah so I think
you've made a really good point about
the area being okay because I think that
sometimes people are attracted to the
good areas because they always I'd like
to live there and that's a problem
because although it's a really nice area
there's no direct correlation between
the house prices and the rents and
you're not going to get the kind of
returns other people get attracted by
the price tag and now my gosh these
houses you can buy the house for 20
grands but you can but it's because it's
in the middle of a red-light district
and there's broken glass everywhere and
you're gonna get stabbed in that Street
but then you want to kind of get this
middle ground which is where the house
that it's not the best neighborhood in
the world and when it's safe and the
people are decent but at the same time
the houses are still cheap and you
manage to get that sweet spot which has
worked out really well for you yeah I
mean that that first thought I would say
I was quite lucky yeah and the house was
on the market at the time forty five
grand
now I I went in and had a look at the
house somebody was already living in it
already and the condition wasn't great
and I went back to the the aging and say
look I've only got five grand you know
for my deposit I liked I like to buy the
house inspect 45 can we come and push it
to like 40 40 grand I'm just asking the
question on the age and ask the vendor
when and say yeah yeah we'll take it for
40 so we get the valuation people to
come in which is the bank yeah a part of
the bank valuator came in and bala at
the house and they said the house
doesn't work 40 grand it's actually
worth 30 I was I was quite this point it
really because I can't pay another 10
grand goes on with a 5 grand
yeah so so I was being really really
cheeky backstage and so look the bank
said but the house doesn't work with
like 40 grand they said 30 grand look
I've only got 5 that I can't afford to
pay anymore by surprise the the it was a
motive you met in the crafts got this
motivated seller
you know motivate buyer and it was a
motivated seller and you were not
motivated buyer which is great I was a
motivated buyer I just look perfect
yeah I just said I've only got five now
and they came back to again we'll set
the 30 grand well you know I was so
surprised and I got the house for 30
grand and again this week when the house
is down valued sometimes the banks will
down value a house and people on Durham
houses down valued now it's in Britain
opportunity to be able to say look the
bank right at this yes I'm prepared to
pay so that was the opportunity but but
the area like he said before I mean I I
have viewed quite a number houses before
I bought the second and third and fourth
but the first one it's just just by
chance
yeah where where I just got this house
that you had some natural some natural
charisma some Hong Kong charisma but
Liam
that's great okay so the other houses
that you brought them so are they and
they already live a book deal in
Liverpool are they all apart from the
first one that you bought are they all
hate your mouth I would call it a sir
dental HMOs okay ones and was when I
learn about this section for the article
for so I've got all kinds in their
portfolio I've got all kinds of their
houses that I bought all through
learning and yeah because when you set
me in the crash course just go and view
a lot of houses yeah I do
about fifty fifty three houses to be
exact
a bunt among those fifty three houses
I've chosen these these ones told me
about these houses that in what what was
it that caught your eye about these
houses and tell me about the houses
firstly the area because yeah I know the
air is the utmost important I mean I
wasn't actually I wasn't too bothered
about the rental cost inside because I
was surprised when I rented that first
house for 450 when everywhere else was
like 375 yes for a 30 grand house I mean
Jesus a lot of rent and because when you
taught us in the crash girls you know
have a look
market research what other people's are
doing and I did that after mmm I looked
at what other peoples are renting out on
their condition of the photograph and in
turn in turn design and décor it was
nowhere near my I must have just got
this not natural thing to get in a high
spec but the not ten months I spent the
money refurbished the first house it was
in a very very good high spec condition
where the high spec it was clean simple
you know you know bright colored yeah I
knew and I literally I put it up on open
rents yeah I didn't get it agent bizarre
you know the agent was didn't find
anyone you didn't find the day I gave
them three weeks are keeping the keys
they brought people in but there was
nothing and I but I put on the open rent
on Sunday because I was sharing one of
my friend who was struggling tribal
renders her flat out I said I found this
one register put it on I'm not sure the
two I'll put my house on yeah and then
I'm not on that evening there's four
requests for viewing for the next day
interesting you know friend of all that
doesn't know open rent is when you put
basically you put it on right move
yourself through because when you put on
open it doesn't so you this your self
yeah I wonder why that is then Satan and
the Eurasian won't let anything out you
put it all right with yourself and then
suddenly boom do you think it might be
because agents prioritized and investors
in certain landlords I have no idea I
mean
I have what wanted.i whoo-hoo quite
confident I've got to get this place
rent out but for three weeks he got my
keys and bringing people in and out but
it was it wasn't the he knows what I
what tenant I need but he wasn't
attending that but you know his network
I suppose is a is I do fall thought you
know to rent my house are all of your
houses are they all properties that need
a refurb are you planning on referring
them and putting the money back out okay
I've got two houses or a tenant in yeah
and once they finish big conveyance II I
will get my straightaway in my rental
income us seen the condition of the two
of these property got among these 11 one
of those in rated the condition for 50
income already it was a tired landlord I
think I've got another house off him
tired landlord but not my property not
type up to Thailand yeah he just wanted
to get you know you know get rid of the
house he rents for 15 obviously haven't
you behind the house for less than 50
grand
how much exam with 47 so you might have
a 47 grand and the rents for 5th day
yeah
the return on investment on these yeah I
don't know you message me yes and we
were chatting I think yesterday before
yesterday and you were saying a bit
worried about a couple of these it's
stressful right yeah but I mean some of
these deals that you've got do yeah
they're crackers yeah I mean they're
they all right well above 20 20 roi 20
percent are a little well above well
above and even though they're really
cheap little houses with 450 rounds some
of them are HMOs I mean amongst the 11 I
know that you know you're gonna be
financially free yeah hopefully when
they're all rented out yeah yeah we did
the best case worst case a lot the gates
to joins him and even the most
pessimistic glasses on in the world
looking at it from the worst worth worth
worth worth case I think it was what 3
grand a month profit yeah so three
random of profit it's not incredible but
yeah for most people
I'll be enough for them sir yeah tick to
quit work of all these lemon houses or
kicks in it will be about 10 guys case
yeah you know you can never
I've learned a bit of property investor
is you can never look at a deal and rely
on best case you always have to rely on
worst case if you making money on worst
case here also
may I know you'll be making warm three
grand but I'm just saying even with no
tenants and some of the houses and
horribly cheap rooms and they're
overpriced builders you still going to
be financially fryer which is just epic
it will yeah how old are you I'm 49 50
in December
financially free by 50 so um that's why
I made four so tell me about the bill
was I know you've had some bad build and
especially prior to coming on the
training with us and you've learned how
to you've now got really good builders
how do you get good builders what
happens I mean perfectly okay I mean
obviously through the network through
through your CAD me and the COS Alistair
has a really good bill there and because
I've shared with him some of the backs
SP and experience that I've been having
with my builder even the local ones
which I thought it was supposed to be
perfect he he said this this this
builder built of Dave I mentioned as
they builded a great name great name and
and he came round had looked at some of
my properties I've learn a lot from him
and he also he didn't criticize that
other house he was just saying that
house is not meeting the acquirement
yeah I need to go back to that building
tell they you'll find builders always
creating other builders yeah you know
they always if a previous girl who's
been out there always yeah but what was
sort of the bad experiences that you had
I know I need to know many things
anything but some of the lessons that
you learn with some of the not so good
builders what happened yeah but I've got
runners I've got disappear or you know
you know lost in action and and delay
you know they did this you know really
time waster you know wasting the time
and never get things done on time the
wonders the disappear is in the deal is
bi delays that right yeah
it's it's really frustrating I mean I
before I met you before I have the
funding hanging through by selling one
of my property in Hong Kong I have to do
like month by month like the project so
so therefore I didn't have enough money
to you know pay or for the whole job
yeah so therefore I I thought is that
because the reason I didn't have the
full funding to do it that's the reason
why being treated in that way but these
these internet bill that I found was men
they gave me like a like a number of
coats I didn't choose the cheapest one I
think choose the most expensive one I
choose the one in the middle and I
thought that should be like a logical
thing today yeah but still a builder who
who who just took my money from my
material I never come back
obviously they bought everything but
they never came back and finish off the
job terrible and I'm done baby they have
everything but they never finished on
time so so it's kind of like you know
what can I do and then and then when I
met you you told me to go to the network
and I met these some builders on the
network the the pin in Liverpool this
guy's who who said he was reputable from
other people saying that you know he
could be a good person shoes because it
experience in building HMO and a lot for
him to do that I choose him to do it and
the problem is that he thought I was an
experienced landlord all these beans
investor yeah and I told them that
wasn't you need to tell me what to do
but he is communicating of
communications very very important yes
and I found the the Builder day you know
from Alistair he was keeping me posted
up today you know without banners we
always have a little what's up group you
know with all the all the people that
are if it's a big project
but even if it's a small project all the
people that are involved with the refurb
we have a good guy and we're just
constantly on that be these these bill
that I had before they don't like
communication yeah even with the class
guy I met in pin he actually on the
water told me to shut up it's not
sending me many more messages and the
message that I'm sending was listing out
the stuff that he needs to do before we
have any miscommunication or
anything don't miss oh you just tell me
can you stop messaging me but you know
he doesn't reply to me so yeah I feel
I've got another one of those build and
again it seems that the people that the
builders in the liver pill you really
have to be very careful
yeah all right you get this one that
really really expensive probably they'll
do a really good job but anything that
eats middle or the you know the big
competitive price yeah yeah they in my
experience it's never been a very good
experience so what are the pine for the
best or find someone highly recommended
in a good Network yes and that's also
part of the you know people say it's
expensive being on the Academy but it
means that you can get the job done a
good price yeah and go wow so it's all
part of what you get that's right I mean
even with this builder from the pin I
must say he said to be specific honey
one of the olivine is I wasn't specific
I mean if I if I was an experienced
investor I would tell me every single
thing what I need it yeah obviously I'm
not this I rely on you give me take the
slight lead are they even an option give
me a choice yeah so you know we know
what that we can either get bitter or
better right yeah you know they be the
are or we can sort of learn from that
yeah I've grown as an investor I've
grown as a person but there are all our
bills out there some of them are bad
some of them they're just yes it's
communication problems yeah I get a lot
of people on one YouTube comments in
saying sandal you're always too hard on
builders there are lot of good builders
out there and there are good bill you
know but there are also bad ones what's
the what's the Academy been like for you
so far I think we're very supportive I
mean the the my classmate and even my
mentors I mean they are all very
supportive I mean one other thing I
would like to say is ok you take action
but maybe not action by 11 houses at the
same time if I can do the second time
I'll probably maybe two or three yeah
manageable because I've been there when
I've got just so I saw it on my play and
even though there's so many resources
that I can you know use to to invest I
never have time yeah I never have time
to go around try them on even I went on
to the service accommodation and Lesley
session I did fire white you know and
the landlord and Ike half reply where
service combination the other supposedly
I had to go out to turn it down
yesterday did you I have to turn it down
because my builder and obviously the
good builder the other day he's got a
lot on already one my building okay I
thought if I was able to rely on this
loco builder this this from the pin I
could have given the job and trying to
refurbish that room and then I can get a
lot and Ronnie I come the focus
um find one strategy until successful
yeah and I guess you can't have done
that with the properties and in value
refinancing rented them out which is
great what long-term date Ellen's once
you've got these lemon houses and you
make in your tank round them up
hopefully even if it's seven live of
that financially free what's next what's
what's the big picture for you big
pictures I will try the other strategy
if you allow me to attend those the
Academy session again
I love refresh because obviously I
haven't be athlete fully commit in
utilizing those different strategy
because of this in eleven houses I've
gotten my plate up again so deal so
since one of them because I'm I do like
viewing these houses and you know even
if I was traveling around outside
Liverpool that will meet my problem
possible aim and give it back yeah you
know to people who like myself you know
once at the start on the property ladder
it's to give them a really good you know
profits to invest them so I would spend
my time and deal source for that service
commendation is some other things that I
might like to look at as well
depending how much money I can pull out
in these houses as well I like to do
joint ventures angel investors yeah
complete each other's laws basically I
mean the I think the definition of a
good property investor is definitely
focusing on one strategy until
successful but when you've got all the
different strategies and you understand
lease options renter and serviced
accommodation joint venture deal
packaging you become like a property
problem solver where you just go meet
people make investors do deals you so I
guess and that's
the things about the Academy we teach
you all the strategies you focus on one
but then once you've smashed that one
you can it's not due to the ones yeah so
sounds like it's gonna be an exciting
the air alter yeah I mean the other
things obviously I I have acquired a
good Network in the Chinese community as
well
yeah myself who who wants to invest I'll
pitch it or there's a lot of other
people once they invest as well I have
quite a number of friends over in Hong
Kong relatives and all grown as well
they have a lot of you know probably a
lot of money in the bank not doing very
much
yeah of course they can't invest in Hong
Kong as their property in in Hong Kong
point quite expensive actually look them
to buy anything at all now I know Alice
there is a couple of people in network
who actually do overseas yeah kind of
investing I like to get involved with
that actually you know just maybe you
know a couple of trip Hong Kong just a
bit of talk and I'm really just to go to
Hong Kong I'll have to bring you with me
yeah and we'll do something out there
what else what's the networking being
like on the Academy there no it's been I
mean the Facebook is really really yes
we have our Facebook and obviously
there's whatsapp there's also the the
video conference as well so so they're
all really great to hear out what other
people actually and what they're doing
yeah and I kind of energizes my
mentality at the moment because people
outside the Academy they all singing
this a different in sheet what we sing
and sometimes quite feel quite lonely I
mean even though I've got my wife on
board
she still had this half heart escaped to
some you know about all this but she
said to me until I see that rental
income comes in you know I'll I believe
that you are on the right track and
that's even more scarier you know
because the things you know I know I
could do it but I knew that I do need
that mental support yeah and the Academy
gave me all that I mean even with the
with the last week the DFB yeah yeah the
o'flanagan's yeah that that is really
good meeting a lot of people who like
myself who are trying to get on you know
into the proper lab but they are also
people who are
the in yeah it just give me no bro I
mean as well yeah you are on that yeah
like you got your housing year ago which
is written out really why you've been
fine it's there you buy houses like more
than more than my wife buys my bags yeah
so so that mental support is really
really good yeah and um thanks sometimes
people sabotage themselves because of
fear so they might get a few houses or
they've got a few years and in the pile
because they haven't got that support I
haven't got people to look over the
deals you know to give them that mental
support and also the friendships and
stuff like that yeah I think the people
that you spend time with the people you
become and people sometimes you can
desire to be 100 already financially for
you can design want to be a property
investor but unless if you're hanging
out regularly I've been dealing with
other people that are doing here it's
just not going to happen
yeah yeah so it's it's been great
meeting either one of the network friend
of my he came up all over London and he
was looking for a house just on the same
street where I got my second ales he
even asked me to come round a block to
his house you know and I went in and
side it's just giving that support yeah
cuz Iggy was so eager behind I think
everybody you just need up but a little
bit that support you know you only gain
and sure I keep on watching this always
suggest that they go find other people
in the business
yeah I'd make friends that doing it like
yeah surround yourself you know surround
just helping people with such energy see
his cuz yeah I needed up keep myself
going especially with these houses on my
place yeah right environment yeah that's
awesome yeah Dave I'm really excited I
mean this has gotta be a plot warm yeah
you've had a lot of success already but
you've also got a lot of properties that
you've just bought and and it's gonna be
really exciting I want to follow you
around the cameras yeah the whole works
man but I'm really proud of ya it's
great to see you killing it
and congratulations always exactly yeah
no thanks thanks tell me thank you
[Music]
[Music]